I'm here because I love you oh by the
way before I get to that I taped it I
laughed so hard you idiots with the nut
spoon but we did it we get a sketch did
you see that we get it sketch was it
last week sketch called nut spoon which
this is really saying something on the
idiocy scale after 24 years of doing
this it was pretty high by our standards
and you saw that it was the the best nut
it was the better the best sketch I've
seen in a long time and I play it for
friends you buy the premise yes yes as
you need a spoon to pick up and yes yes
I was saying I'm an expert yeah I can go
in there and straighten them out yeah
you pick up and up with a finger yeah
yeah no no this is the whole premise of
the sketches you got easily wounded wow
I can't believe a you saw it B you liked
it and see you're showing it to other
people makes my life
you